we set our goals in the beginning
because they will affect the rest of the
decisions we make for example if our
goal is related to brand awareness we
may choose to advertise on Billboard's
and their online equivalent to
billboards display ads if your goal is
driving more traffic to your website
you'd probably focus your advertising
with online ads with clear
call-to-action like join us today and
get free membership for a year if your
goals were very specific to one segment
or audience or location then you may
choose some local channels to advertise
on it might be hanging posters in the
local dog park or having your online ad
on the home page of a local popular
business in your town for us one of the
goals we set for abarkment is to
increase traffic of dog owners to our
website 5% monthly that means that we're
going to focus our marketing plan on
online ads that target our niche
audience we might also produce a funny
video of fancy dogs and a call to action
at the end that says receive our
promotional offer or a launch special
and then we're just going to hope the
video goes viral and we get even more
customers
now her goal were brand awareness we'd
probably prefer to use display ads on
dog related websites or run a Facebook
Pinterest or Google+ campaign inside dog
owner communities